foreign
[Music]
one of my faves UFOs have long been a
source of mystery and Fascination in
1951's The Day the Earth Stood Still
Hollywood imagined what would happen if
an alien spaceship landed on the capitol
mall well this week a U.S government
agency charged with investigating
unidentified flying objects released its
annual report and David Martin has the
details on what was found
oh God
this is just one of 510 UFO sightings
mostly by Navy and Air Force pilots over
the past two decades more than half of
which remain unexplained it does become
increasingly clear that unidentified
aerial phenomenon are not a rare
occurrence last year Congressman Andre
Carson chaired the first public hearing
on what the government calls
unidentified aerial phenomena it
provided precious few answers about
where they came from I would simply say
that there are a number of of events in
which we do not have an explanation this
week a new report from the Director of
National Intelligence revealed that 169
sightings turned out to be balloons or
some kind of Airborne clutter while 26
turned out to be drones the obvious
question is whose drones precisely I
mean are they drones from our U.S
military are they drones from the
private sector are they drones from
other state actors who are also
adversaries these green triangles cited
by Navy ships off the coast of
California in 2019 turned out to be
drones
they appeared at the same time Chinese
Merchant vessels were in the area
there's no proof the drones came from
those ships but one U.S official said
China is highly suspect in all these
sightings now we've got 510 has any
physical evidence such as debris been
recovered the debris that has been
recovered has not raised any notable
alarms and that's as much as I'll say in
other words no alien spacecraft but
there are still UFOs that maneuver in
ways that baffle America's best fighter
pilots and the man who was once their
commander-in-chief we can't explain
uh
how they moved
their trajectory you know I think that
we're people still take seriously trying
to investigate and figure out what that
is intelligence agencies have now been
ordered to extend their investigation
all the way back to 1947 when the crash
of a weather balloon in Roswell New
Mexico set off the decades-long search
for UFOs for CBS Saturday morning this
is David Martin at the Pentagon
yes those 40 years before the last 20
I'm interested in it's great fun to talk
about yeah no notable alarms notable no
notable alarms okay just a second very
nice thank you David Martin